berthe avec notre invité mathieu au
qu'il est responsable du pôle politique
au think tank le millénaire match choc
bonjour bienvenue sur rt france à
l'heure on l'a vu un lourd dispositif de
sécurité
cet après midi interpellation de jérôme
rodriguez 1 figurent des eyzies déjeuner
soutien de ce convoi de la liberté une
première réaction
ce qui ce qui est intéressant dans la
réaction du gouvernement c'est qu'il
aussi entre les paroles entre l'appel au
calme à part à travers le discours d'
emmanuel macron et les paroles des
réelles macro et de et de débris à la
talent et la politique de fermeté en cas
de blocage donc la ligne rouge avait été
mise et inscrite sur la question du
blocage des grandes artères parisiennes
et notamment des champs-elysées on voit
que sur la partie appel au calme c'est
la première réaction qu'on peut avoir
c'est que les déclarations du chef de
l'état elle s'inscrit plutôt dans une
logique de précampagne présidentielle à
sa réélection sur la partie plutôt
fermeté on voit que un dispositif
important inédit depuis les gilets
jaunes avec l'interdiction par la
préfecture de police de manifester des
verbalisations bhl avait rappelé plus de
300 verbalisation et 7000 policiers font
que effectivement on aussi un petit peu
dans une stratégie du en même temps
entre appels au calme et fermeté et
ferme fermeté policière alors c'est
difficile d'analyser ce qui se passe
actuellement le convoi de la liberté en
france vient de prendre forme at il des
chances comme au canada de s'inscrire
dans le temps
c'est effectivement tout là toute la
question qu'on va se poser d'ailleurs il
sent qu'il s'inscrira dans le temps un
peu comme les gilet jaune on voit qu'on
est lent qu'on a là en face de nous un
mouvement un mouvement social est un
mouvement politique qui n'est et qui
s'inscrit à un petit peu dans le
continuum de ce qu'ont été les gilets
jaunes en 2018 2019 avec trois points
qu'on peut qu'on peut mettre en avant et
qui pourrait peut-être à terme
déstabiliser la campagne présidentielle
dans un premier temps il s'agit d'un
mouvement spontané de citoyens qui ont
utilisé les réseaux sociaux pour pouvoir
se rassembler et de citoyens qui sont
sur des profils plutôt hétéroclite le
dernier papier du monde nous le montrait
bien on est sur des profils plutôt de
classes populaires de classe
intermédiaire qui viennent d'eux et
c'est le second point de la france
périphérie urbaine une france
périurbaines qui subit le déclassement
politique économique et démographique
depuis quasiment 40 ans et qui a un
certain ras-le-bol cristallisée par la
politique sanitaire du gouvernement
et puis le troisième point c'est c'est
l'idée que ce mouvement qui s'est
déclarée de fait comme les gilets jaunes
à politique refusant la récupération et
dont les figures inspirante n'était non
pas les élites politiques est plutôt des
personnalités de la société civile on
pense au professeur didier rahout et
c'est ce que les manifestants ont scandé
sur les sur les champs-elysées est-ce
qu'il s'inscrira dans le temps par
rapport au canada c'est à voir mais en
tout cas le premier point qu'on peut on
peut mettre en avant c'est
cette dimension apolitique qui va
ensuite avoir des répercussions
potentielles sur la campagne
présidentielle
alors si on rappelle en ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans la capitale il ya ce
convoi de la liberté il y à des
rassemblements de gilet jaune il y à des
manifestations anti pas cinq comme celle
chaque samedi sur appel du leader
politique florian philippot est ce qu'on
arrive à ce que l'on qualifie de
convergence des luttes
alors ce que ce qui est intéressant de
voir c'est que les revendications elles
sont multiples on a des revendications à
la base un peu comme le sur le modèle
canadien et américain dès qu'on verra d
une bataille sur la question sanitaire
et la question de l'obligation vaccinale
donc des routiers plus généralement
ensuite de la population c'est ce qui
est portée par les manifestants
aujourd'hui
dans un second temps on a des
revendications effectivement politiques
la démission du président de la
république la démission de l'as des
députés a démission du gouvernement des
revendications aussi économiques et vous
l'avez rappelé aussi sur les thématiques
du pouvoir d'achat commencent à émerger
dans le débat public et puis même
d'aider c'est la singularité un peu
française des
revendications d'ordre plutôt
démocratiques et institutionnelles refus
des directives européennes et la
question du référendum d'initiative
populaire la convergence des luttes pour
l'instant elle est encore théorique lll
elle arrivera peut-être dans les
prochaines dans les prochaines semaines
si le mouvement arrive à s'inscrire
davantage dans la durée
mathieu ok merci d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes responsable du
pôle politique au think tank le
millénaire